good morning believe nation today's  message is believe in yourself over the  youth Snoop Dogg I just I just go back  to the time when I was young and I  didn't know what I wanted to do in life  and once I finally grabbed ahold to what  I wanted to do which was this music  thing  and I loved every minute of it despite  me not being able to make money or have  a career I had to believe in myself and  I want to say that to the youngsters out  there that's watching you know believe  in anything that you believe that but  have the most believing it's yourself  whether it's being a doctor a lawyer or  a chemist or whatever it is you have to  believe yourself and then once you  believe the dream will come true and if  people will believe in you that's what  dreams are made of  you have to believe in it and then a  dream can come to life